und heute haben die fraktionen schon
einmal getagt die im boot die fraktionen
im bundestag und haben sich positioniert
ich gebe jetzt ab nach berlin an meinen
kollegen alexander
klaws in einigen tagen ja übrigens noch
hier die cdu csu fraktion zum beispiel
die wird jetzt ja auch gleich hier mit
ralph brinkhaus als fraktionschef ein
kurzes statement abgeben
einige fraktionen wie die grünen tagen
digital die anderen hier mit präsenz wie
cdu csu und spd und jetzt könnt ihr
gleich weitergeben der fraktionschef von
ralph brinkhaus der fraktionschef der
unionsfraktion
der wird jetzt an bei ihm sepp müller
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
mit dem geschäftsfeld gesundheit
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zum presse statement vor der
fraktionssitzung mit herrn brinkhaus und
herrn müller herzlich willkommen auch
von meiner seite in allen erstmal sofern
wir uns noch nicht gesehen haben ein
gutes jahr
2022 es wird ein spannendes jahr werden
bei uns in einer anderen rolle jetzt als
opposition aber wir haben die rolle
angenommen wir sind als fraktion
aufgestellt wir werden heute noch die
stellvertretenden arbeitsgruppen
sprecher wählen und dann sind wir auch
voll handlungsfähig dann weiß jeder was
er zu tun hat und die fraktion brennt
jetzt auch in die oppositionsarbeit
einzusteigen und das haben wir ja auch
in den vergangenen wochen schon gemacht
es ist so dass wir viele themen haben
wir haben natürlich das thema corona und
impfen deswegen habe ich heute sehr
müller mitgebracht der als neuer
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
für dieses thema zuständig ist aber wir
haben auch noch zwei andere
ereignisse auf die ich eingehen möchte
aber vorher möchte ich also auch noch
mal meine trauer ausdrücken dass der
präsident des europäischen parlamentes
herr soli verstorben ist es war ein
überzeugter europäer nicht in unserer
partei aber es war ein fairer partner
und das ist ein großer verlust für
europa und unsere gedanken sind bei
seinen angehörigen
hier in deutschland ist es so dass
robert habeck heute seine
eröffnungsbilanz vorgestellt hat wie er
mit dem klimawandel umgehen möchte und
was er dagegen machen möchte wir
unterstützen ihn bei dem weg die ziele
zu erreichen die wir uns gemeinsam auch
in der letzten legislaturperiode gegeben
haben auch eine menge auf die vorgänger
und stellt die situation auch sehr
dramatisch da das ist das recht von
jemanden der neu in das amt gekommen ist
es ist aber auch richtig dass wir mehr
geschwindigkeit hineinbringen müssen in
diesem gesamten prozess und da
unterstützen wir ihnen auch in dem punkt
geschwindigkeit in den kampf gegen den
klimawandel hineinzubringen dabei geht
es nicht nur um das thema erneuerbare
energien
da wird einiges zu tun sein um den
spagat hin zu kriegen gerade im bereich
windkraft im land zwischen artenschutz
auf der einen seite windkraft auf der
anderen seite zwischen den bedenken und
interessen der bürgerinnen und bürger
aber wir werden diesen weg mit ihm
zusammen gehen aber das reicht nicht wir
müssen auch über andere themen sprechen
wir müssen zum beispiel darüber sprechen
dass wir mehr machen müssen um die
energieeffizienz zu steigern und das ist
nicht nur die energieeffizienz im
bereich der energie verbrauche im
klassischen sinne sondern dabei geht es
auch um ressourcenschonung insgesamt da
ist ein enger schulterschluss auch mit
den umwelt politikerinnen und politiker
notwendig da geht es auch um recycling
da geht es um geringerem
ressourceneinsatz was uns in dem bereich
auch am herzen liegt und da hätte man
auch ein bisschen mehr zu machen können
das sind die klimaschutz verträge die
man mit der industrie abschließt wenn
die industrie mehr
investitionssicherheit haben möchte um
zum beispiel auf grünen wasserstoff
umzusteigen wenn die industrie eine
investitionssicherheit haben möchte um
beispielsweise auch hier trotz
gestiegener energiekosten aufgrund
unseres wegs in der erneuerbaren
energien hinein weiter am standort zu
bleiben dann brauchen wir diese verträge
und das ist ganz ganz wichtig dass diese
verträge abgeschlossen werden was auch
sehr sehr wichtig ist ist das thema
leitungsausbau da sind wir in den
vergangenen jahren zu langsam gewesen
leitungsausbau ist einer der
schlüsselelemente im kampf gegen den
klimawandel
und auch da muss mehr geschwindigkeit
reinkommen wir bieten robert habeck
unsere gesprächsbereitschaft an wir
bieten ihm unsere konstruktive mitarbeit
an was aber auch richtig ist ist das wir
einen punkt besonders mit euch müssen
dass wir nicht alle erneuerbaren
energien nicht allen grünen wasserstoff
den wir hier in deutschland brauchen bei
uns herstellen können deswegen müssen
wir mehr reden und das hätte man auch in
dem papier noch intensiver beleuchtet
müssen da sind wir gespannt auf die
vorschläge der bundesregierung das heißt
um den europäischen strommarkt aber auch
wie wir regenerative energien aus
ländern importieren wo sonne und wind im
überfluss da ist ich denke da haben wir
eine menge zu tun eine sache die hat
nicht nur was mit dem bereich
klimawandel zu tun das ist die planungs
beschleunigung natürlich ist es wichtig
das war der planungs beschleunigung
hinkriegen übrigens nicht nur für
windkraftanlagen sondern auch für
energie leitung wir wollen in
deutschland takt in der bahn haben auch
für neue bahnlinien aber planungs
beschleunigung von bauvorhaben das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt der nicht auch
in meinem heimatland nordrhein westfalen
bewegt sie wissen dass das die talbrücke
den rahmen der bei der a 540 nicht mehr
benutzbar ist und es ist im interesse
der region weil das eine ganz wichtige
verkehrsachse ist dass wir da sehr sehr
schnell sind und auch da wären wir sehr
konstruktiv mit volker wissing
zusammenarbeiten wenn es darum geht eine
bau- und eine planungs beschleunigung
hinzukriegen gestern hatten wir eine
anhörung zum thema nachtragshaushalt sie
wissen dass christian lindner ein
nachtragshaushalt eingebracht hat wo es
darum geht kreditermächtigungen die
eigentlich für die korona bekämpfung
notwendig gewesen wären auf das neue
jahr vorzutragen für andere projekte
einzusetzen wir halten das für
verfassungswidrig wir halten das für
ganz ganz schwierig dass das im einklang
zu bringen ist mit der schuldenbremse
die meisten gutachter haben uns gestern
recht gegeben wir werden jetzt in die
parlamentarischen beratungen mit dem
ergebnis der anhörung hineingehen und
notfalls wenn die bundesregierung auf
das was die gutachter sagt nicht hört
werden wir uns auch vorbehalten vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu gehen wir
sind gespannt wie das dort weitergeht
sie sehen wir sind in vielen themen
nicht nur im chor oder thema angekommen
wir sind mitten im laufenden geschäft
die ministerinnen und minister werden
diese woche ihre kleinen
regierungserklärung abgeben wir haben
eine woche wo jedes ressort vorstellen
kann was geplant ist wo die schwerpunkte
sind und wir werden da die ersten
akzente auch in der opposition setzen
und zum thema corona wird jetzt sepp
müller berichten ja mittlerweile über
100.000 tote in deutschland zu beklagen
weil sie mal halb millionen infizierten
die zahlen sind dramatisch die vierte
welt es abgebrochen die fünfte wann
tommy konvent für uns und die regierung
versagt mittlerweile beim dritten
versprechen das erste versprechen 30
millionen booster impfung wurden nicht
eingehalten das zweite versprechen bis
ende januar 80 prozent der menschen in
deutschland zu immunisieren mit einer
erstimpfung ist wird nicht eingehalten
und auch das versprechen des
bundeskanzler olaf scholz das bis
februar ein impfpflicht
eingereicht wird kann nicht eingehalten
werden wir als unionsfraktion haben uns
aufgrund dieser versprechen in die spur
gemacht und bereits vor weihnachten eine
vielzahl an fragen an die
bundesregierung hier in persona an den
bundeskanzler geschickt diese fragen
konnten nicht beantwortet werden wurden
nicht beantwortet deswegen haben wir den
offiziellen weg der kleinen anfrage
hinterhergeschoben jetzt ist es wichtig
diese wand zu brechen dazu gehören
einerseits die schnelltests was das paul
ehrlich institut heute gemacht hat noch
mal auf dem neuesten stand zu bringen 30
prozent sind nicht brauchbar wir müssen
die pcr kapazitäten laborkapazitäten
deutlich ausweiten er geht wie nun
oberösterreich ein gutes beispiel voran
mit den pc ergo gilt es gerade in den
variablen gruppen und den schulen und
kitas und gleichzeitig müssen wir die
ersten quote nach oben führen da stellt
sich die frage des datenschutzes wie wir
beispielsweise die daten des
einwohnermeldeamtes aber auch die daten
der krankenkassen nutzen können um die
menschen an zu schreiben darauf
hinzuweisen dass impfen hilft das impfen
gegen omikron hilft nicht in eine
schwierige situation auf den kranken aus
stationen zu gelangen die wand wird
kommen da sie die wehr hat heute
berechnet dass innerhalb der nächsten
acht wochen 50 prozent der europäer mit
omikron sich infizieren werden wir
werden trotz einer geringeren
krankenhauseinweisungen bei omikron
trotzdem eine belastung des
gesundheitssystems sehen und deswegen
fordern wir die bundesregierung wir
fordern olaf scholz auf endlich etwas
vorzulegen um die ersten quoten nach
oben zu bringen
vielen dank kommen wir nun zu ihren
fragen frau schweizer vom mdr bitte
vielen dank ich habe zwei komplex einmal
zu robert habeck nachgefragt müsste man
es nicht sogar schärfer formulieren auf
der einen seite sagt der atome und gas
sind keine grünen energien auf der
anderen seite sollen gaskraftwerk
ausgebaut werden ist das nicht
scheinheilig und die zweite frage zur
impfpflicht da gab es ja einen vorstoß
aus den eigenen reihen
wird da die union mit einem eigenen
antrag
starten und kommt das nicht sogar
sowieso viel zu spät von omikron da
schon längst vorbei ist naja also jetzt
gas das ist das ankommt von robert
habeck und den grünen in der realität
also wir werden also ohne erdgas was
natürlich möglichst schnell auch
umgestellt werden soll beispielsweise in
grünem wasserstoff werden nicht
auskommen also wir können nicht also aus
der kohle aussteigen aus der kernenergie
aussteigen und so wie sich der eine oder
andere grüne das vorstellt dann also
auch sofort aus dem gas aus oder der
gasse verbrennung aussteigen das wird
nicht gehen so wünschenswert dass auch
ist und insofern also herzlich
willkommen in der realität der
energiewende das ist dann halt
regierungshandeln dass man sowas mit auf
den weg bringen muss und beim thema
impfen ist es so da ist jetzt erstmal
die regierung in der vorlage es ist ein
sehr kompliziertes thema wir haben
übrigens bereits eine impfpflicht in
deutschland nämlich für die menschen in
den gesundheitsberufen berufen und
inwieweit man diese impfpflicht jetzt so
ausweitet das sind viele fragen zu
beantworten und sehr müller hat das
gerade gesagt wir haben auch viele
fragen die als grundlage für dafür die
gesundheitspolitische fragen app
ideologische fragen ethische fragen
verfassungsrechtliche fragen an die
bundesregierung gestellt die haben ein
paar tausend leute um diese fragen zu
beantworten und dementsprechend warten
wir darauf wir werden aber nicht warten
bis wir die antworten kriegen wir haben
heute abend eine fraktion offene sitzung
wo wir eine vertreterin des ethikrates
und verfassungsrechtlern epidemiologen
eingeladen haben und wo wir ganz ganz
viele fragen haben werden und da auch
versuchen eine meinung und zu bilden
ansonsten gilt das war es immer gegolten
hat die cdu und die csu sind parteien
mit einem breiten meinungsbild aber wir
werden das alles irgendwo wieder
zusammenführen und werden dann also als
fraktion auch das angebot machen mit der
regierung zu sprechen ist konstruktiv zu
begleiten ich habe das in den letzten
wochen schon mal gesagt wenn man in eine
impfpflicht hinein geht dann ist das
eine sache die einen breiten
demokratischen konsens braucht und nicht
eine situation wo man dann viel
gruppenanträge hatte und ein
gruppenantrag sich dann irgendwo knapp
durchsetzt weil das muss von allen
demokratischen parteien dann auch
mitgetragen werden und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass die regierung das die
regierung tragenden fraktionen schnell
gespräche mit uns aufnehmen wir sind
dazu bereit
ja soweit ralph brinkhaus kleine
korrektur von mir auch die cdu csu
fraktion tagt heute digital und nicht
wie ich schon gesagt habe in präsenz ja
das thema in pflicht das wird das erste
quartal in diesem jahr ganz bestimmt
bestimmen soll ja eine erste
orientierung debatte in der übernächsten
woche geben in der nächsten
sitzungswoche aber dieses thema wird
auch diese woche schon bestimmen obwohl
im parlament dazu ja nichts beschlossen
werden wird ein ganz wichtiges thema ist
die impfpflicht natürlich auch für die
fdp wo man manches anders sieht als in
der union und zum thema impfpflicht und
breiten demokratischen konsens da werden
wir in den nächsten tagen und wochen
sicherlich noch einiges möglicherweise
auch kurioses hören nächster im reigen
der fraktionsvorsitzenden christian dürr
von der fdp
ich unterstütze ausdrücklich die
vorschläge der ministerpräsidenten
konferenz zur verkürzung der quarantäne
zeiten und isolations zeiten denn das
hält die arbeitsfähigkeit auch der
kritischen infrastruktur in deutschland
aber sicherlich auch der
mittelständischen wirtschaft in gang das
ist dadurch sichergestellt und will an
dieser stelle sagen dass ich auch
ausdrücklich betonen will ist vielleicht
ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen den
letzten tagen gerade das auch
schülerinnen und schüler sich jetzt
verkürzt frei testen können diejenigen
die sogar frisch doppelt geimpft keine
quarantäne mehr macht durchmachen müssen
das stellt sicher dass die kinder in
deutschland die jugendlichen am
unterricht teilnehmen können und nicht
den anschluss verlieren das ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt auch für uns freie
demokraten gewesen wir werden als
fdp-fraktion den neuen quarantäne regeln
in dieser woche natürlich auch im
deutschen bundestag entsprechend
zustimmen und unterstützen auch den
wunsch der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dass die impfkampagne mit hochdruck
fortgesetzt wird
und ich will betonen dass wir trotz
einer neuen virus variante ist schaffen
das gesellschaftliche leben in gang zu
halten wenn man sich schaut wie die
letzte winter krise abgelaufen ist mit
ausgangssperren mit schulschließungen
mit lockdown dann unterscheidet sich das
wohltuend wie es in diesem jahr abläuft
und für uns geht nach wie vor eines
nämlich dass maßnahmen wirksam sein
müssen und danach beurteilen wie auch
die maßnahmen die vorgeschlagen werden
und das unterscheidet uns meine ich
jedenfalls auch so manchen vorschlägen
aus der union die doch eher aus meiner
sicht den eindruck erweckt hatten dass
es um politisches marketing geht anstatt
die gesundheitskrise wirksam zu begegnen
in diesem zusammenhang natürlich auch
ein paar worte zum thema impfpflicht und
zur aktuellen debatte dazu die ampel
partner das wissen sie haben sich ja
darauf verständigt dass wir zunächst
eine orientierungs debatte führen das
werden wir in der kommenden
sitzungswoche des deutschen bundestages
tun bei dieser orientierungs debatte
wird es noch keine gruppenanträge geben
sondern es wird erstmal darum gehen dass
die kollegen kollegen des deutschen
bundestages ihre
derzeitige meinung dazu äußern und dann
werden wir sicherlich auch mit experten
darüber sprechen welche möglichen
gruppenanträge es geben kann und werden
dann vertieft in die debatte einsteigen
denn das ganze ist aus unserer sicht
eine medizin ethische frage und keine
parteipolitische deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir nicht entlang von
fraktionsgrenzen das ganze diskutieren
sondern eben in der sache und auch mit
experten sorgfältig abwägen werden
welche überlegen muss geben kann und
dabei ist mir wichtig zu betonen es gibt
nicht nur schwarz und weiß es gibt nicht
nur pro oder gegen eine impfpflicht
sondern kann es auch abstufungen geben
ich habe mit interesse zur kenntnis
genommen dass aus den reihen der unions
fraktion ja der wunsch geäußert worden
ist die ampelkoalition eine
regierungsvorlage hier erstellen soll
ich fand auch bemerkenswert die äußerung
des kollegen brinkhaus in der
vergangenen woche der ja gesagt hat dass
seine fraktion nicht in der lage ist
hier eine einen vorschlag zu machen
umso mehr freue ich mich dass die
mitglieder der unionsfraktion das
offensichtlich anders sehen der kollege
paul singer hat ja angekündigt dass er
einen vorschlag für eine differenzierte
in pflicht machen möchte wir haben
mittlerweile auch einige kollegen der
unions fraktion die sich eher vorstellen
könnten die impfpflicht abzulehnen also
das zeigt mir dass da doch jetzt eine
debatte über fraktionsgrenzen hinweg in
gang kommt und das ist glaube ich auch
richtig denn am ende muss das was der
deutsche bundestag nach einer solchen
debatte entscheidet für die menschen
nachvollziehbar sein und die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir eben in
der sache diskutieren auch die ethischen
fragen abwägen und dann am ende zu einer
entscheidung kommen und an dem punkt ist
mir eins wichtig zu betonen eine
mögliche impfpflicht hat keinen einfluss
auf die aktuelle unicom wellen sondern
eine mögliche impfpflicht kann die
pandemie mittelfristig gegebenenfalls
bekämpfen und ist insbesondere auf den
kommenden herbst ausgerichtet darin sind
sich ja alle medizinerinnen und
mediziner einig und von daher geht es
jetzt hier nicht darum kurzfristig eine
entscheidung zu treffen sondern eine
fundierte entscheidung und da sind
sicherlich noch viele fakten abzuwägen
auf derer dann ethisch entschieden
werden kann
wo hat er in der fdp fraktion
ja es gibt ja die zeit von etwa 30
nahmen die sagen ich kann mich eher
einer der impfpflicht er nicht nähern
und würde einem solchen antrag dann
zwischen das wäre kein gesetzentwurf
weil es keine änderung der rechtslage
ist aber davon abgesehen schauen wir mal
viele viele viele kollegen meiner
fraktion nicht eingeschlossen sind
zurzeit nicht entschlossen und ich finde
das vorhin schon betont das gehört zur
ehrlichkeit von politikern auch dazu
wenn sie sagen ich kann jetzt noch nicht
abschließend ein meinungsbild geben ich
weiß dass es nachvollziehbare weise von
journalistischer weise den wunsch gibt
dass politiker sich schnell festlegen
ich finde zu ehrlichkeit gehört dazu
dass man es nicht tun kann dass man es
dann auch sagt herr frey hat eigentlich
schon ein paar sänger wieder kassiert
heute mittag im sinne von es wird eben
diese gruppen anträge aus der union
nicht geben und betont das sei eben
keine gewissensentscheidung
weil es nicht über leben und tod
entscheiden würde insofern inwiefern
blockiert da quasi sozusagen jetzt die
union das von der ampel angestrebte
vorgehen bei dieser frage was antworten
sie hat frei und vielleicht auch was
antwort sie herrn söder der ja am
wochenende gesagt hat sinngemäß dass wir
eine aufgabe die ein einzelner
abgeordneter gar nicht bewerkstelligen
könnte da so tief durchzudringen und das
zu entscheiden ich antworte herrn frey
antwort herrn söder und auch reis
brinkhaus mit seinen äußerungen der
letzten woche dazu dass sie ihre eigenen
abgeordneten massiv unterschätzen ich
halte die unionsabgeordneten genau sie
meine kollegen kollegen und die kollegen
eigentlich fast aller fraktion mit
ausnahme einer fraktionen des hauses in
der lage sich nicht nur ein eigenes
meinungsbild zu machen sondern auch
eigene anträge zu erarbeiten
an der stelle übrigens und das hat die
bundesregierung bereits erklärt auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister wenn es darum
geht konkrete juristische
entwürfe also sogenannte
formulierungshilfe zu liefern da ist die
bundesregierung ja jederzeit jede bereit
jede fraktion zu unterstützen aber davor
geschaltete muss ja die ethische
entscheidung stattfinden auf der dann
juristische formulierung passieren und
ich glaube dass herr frey mit der
aussage ich will nicht zu nahe treten
als parlament der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der union aber
ich halte es wirklich für falsch sein
seine abgeordneten so an die seite zu
drücken
soweit christian dürre hat die 30
abgeordneten in seiner fraktion erwähnt
die um den bundestags vize präsidenten
wolfgang kubicki herum jegliche
impfpflicht ablehnen mit den
abgeordneten fdp zusammen wären das
waren etwa 100 abgeordnete im bundestag
von 736 generell gegen eine impfpflicht
wären eigentlich könnten wir uns jetzt
die erklärung der afg dazu auch schon
anziehen aber das statement der
fraktionsspitze das verzögert sich noch
etwas deswegen ziehen wir die bündnis
grünen vor mit der co vorsitzenden der
fraktion katharina dröge die hat sich
auch zum impfen zu im pflicht zur corona
beschränkungen geäußert aber natürlich
auch zu dem auftritt ihres noch
parteivorsitzenden und jetzigen
bundeswirtschaftsminister erobert habe
heute morgen vor der
bundespressekonferenz thema eine
eröffnungsbilanz zur klimaschutzpolitik
mit blick auf die kommende sitzungswoche
werden wir einen ausblick auf die großen
auf die zentralen projekte dieser
legislaturperiode
richten und will als fraktionen werden
dabei natürlich unsere akzente setzen
für uns als grüne bundestagsfraktion
steht im mittelpunkt dass wir das sind
zentrale jahrzehnt im kampf gegen die
klimakrise begonnen haben und herr
minister habeck hat heute morgen in
seiner eröffnungsbilanz noch einmal
deutlich gemacht wie weit entfernt wie
in deutschland aktuell davon sind das
notwendige erreicht zu haben deswegen
ist es nach einem verlorenen jahrzehnt
sachen klimaschutz einem jahrzehnt des
stillstand ist so notwendig dass jetzt
die koalitionsfraktion vereinbart haben
den turbo einzuschalten beim klimaschutz
endlich ins handeln zu kommen wir als
grüne bundestagsfraktion werden mit
allen mitteln unterstützen dass wir
jetzt direkt im ersten halbjahr dieser
neuen koalition einen turbo beim ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien eine offensive
bei der solarenergie bei der ausweisung
von zusätzlichen wind flächen und bei
der planungs beschleunigung hinlegen das
ist notwendig um die weichen zu stellen
um zurückzukommen auf den 15 abfahrt
aber der anspruch in sachen klimaschutz
begrenzt sich natürlich nicht auf die
stromerzeugung auch die sektoren wärme
und industrie sind diejenigen die wir
angehen werden wir kurzfristig erste
maßnahme greifen werden die zweite große
herausforderung der sich die
koalitionsfraktionen auch in diesem jahr
stellen werden ist die bekämpfung der
korona pandemie wir wissen aus den
europäischen nachbarstaaten dass die
entwicklung der neuen omikron variante
zu sehr sehr schnellen verläufen führend
wird deswegen war es notwendig dass die
ministerpräsidentin sich am vergangenen
freitag auf weitere maßnahmen
verständigt haben um die ausbreitung des
corona virus einzudämmen wir als grüne
bundestagsfraktion haben immer gesagt
wir stehen auch kurzfristig bereit
weitere maßnahmen zu ergreifen auch im
rahmen von sondersitzungen wenn dies
notwendig ist eine zentrale maßnahme ist
natürlich das impfen wir haben es
geschafft schon vor weihnachten das ziel
von 30 millionen impfdosen zusätzlich zu
erreichen in diesem tempo werden wir
weiter machen das müssen wir fortsetzen
im deutschen bundestag beginnt jetzt
auch die debatte um eine allgemeine
impfpflicht in der nächsten woche wird
es eine sogenannte orientierungs debatte
gegeben ich finde es richtig dass es
gruppen anträge gibt um diese allgemeine
impfpflicht auf den weg zu bringen
zeitnah auf den weg zu bringen aber auf
der anderen seite auch in einem
sorgfältigen parlamentarischen verfahren
denn es gibt viele fragen von denen die
menschen erwarten dass wir sie im
parlament sorgfältig wägen und wir
möchten am ende breite parlamentarische
mehrheiten haben für diese impfpflicht
dazu laden wir auch die demokratischen
oppositionsfraktionen 1
gleichzeitig wird aktuell über die
gestiegenen verbraucherpreise diskutiert
und insbesondere menschen mit geringem
einkommen sind hiervon natürlich stärker
getroffen deswegen haben wir uns
entschieden maßnahmen die sozial gerecht
sind und gezielt entlasten nach vorne zu
bringen dazu gehört ein
heizkostenzuschuss für bezieherinnen von
wohngeld wir werden auch sehr schnell
ein kinderzuschlag auf den weg bringen
für familien mit geringem einkommen
haben angekündigt den co2 preis zwischen
mieter und vermieter gerecht zu
verteilen und wir werden auch im
nächsten jahr die eeg-umlage vollständig
im bundeshaushalt finanzieren all das
sind maßnahmen die besonders gezielt
auch menschen mit geringem einkommen und
familien entlasten wir haben miteinander
vereinbart dass es in der nächsten
sitzungswoche eine sogenannte
orientierungs debatte gibt dass es
üblich bei gruppen verfahren das es im
bundestag zunächst eine orientierungs
debatte gibt sich danach die gruppen
zusammenfinden vorschläge erarbeiten und
die dann ins parlamentarische verfahren
bringen wir wissen aus den erfahrungen
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
dass eine allgemeine impfpflicht nicht
mehr zur bekämpfung dieser corona welle
geeignet ist wenn man sich anschaut dass
menschen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
erstmal erfüllen müssen das heißt wenn
sie sich jetzt zum ersten mal impfen das
richtet sich insbesondere an menschen
die sich noch nicht für die erste
impfung entschieden haben wenn sie sich
jetzt zum ersten mal im zum zweiten mal
impfen und dann zwei wochen vergehen bis
der vollständigen impfschutz nach der
zweiten impfung erreicht ist wenn es das
ein zeitraum den die menschen erstmal
erfüllen können müssen bevor sie dann
auch unter die allgemeine impfpflicht
fallen und deswegen wird es einige zeit
dauern bis die allgemeine impfpflicht
wirken kann deswegen haben wir immer
gesagt dass keine maßnahme mehr gegen
diese welle sondern die vorsorge gegen
die nächste welle das parlamentarische
verfahren beginnt jetzt und wir haben
auf der einen seite den anspruch dass
sehr zügig zu gestalten da stehen wir
als grüne bundestagsfraktion immer für
bereit solche verfahren zügig zu
gestalten aber wir werden sie auch mit
der notwendigen sorgfalt machen wir
brauchen experten anhörung mit experten
unterschiedlicher professionen sieht
sich dazu äussern müssen dann gesagt
werden erstmal anfang januar die
stellungnahme des deutschen ethikrates
abwarten das war aus unserer sicht
wichtig bei einer frage die so
weitreichend ist in die die menschen in
diesem land so bewegt wie eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ist es notwendig
dass wir sorgfältig wägen und dann auch
einen guten gesetzentwurf vorlegen
soweit katharina drücke von den
bündnisgrünen in fünf minuten etwa um 15
uhr wird die versammelte partei und
fraktionsspitze der linken den
bundespräsidenten kandidatin der partei
für die bundespräsidentenwahl am 13
februar vorstellen gerhard trabert so
lange gehen wir noch zur afd die sich
jetzt auch äußert zur laufenden
parlamentswoche mit der fraktionsspitze
alles eitel und kino kubala der beginnt
so feierte pressevertreter herzlich
willkommen zu unserem kurz statements
vor der fraktionssitzung am heutigen
dienstag ich möchte vielleicht kurz
eingehend auf die beschlüsse der
bundesregierung zu den neuen corona
maßnahmen die getroffen wurden vorwoche
deutschland setzt seinen irrweg in der
korona politik unverdrossen fort start
im umgang mit krone bei steigenden
inzidenz werten einen kühlen kopf zu
bewahren wie viele unserer nachbarländer
ist mittlerweile ja auch zeigen setzt
auch die scholz regierung nach wie vor
weiter auf panikmache und verschärft
reflexartig die große maßnahmen ohne
rücksicht auf mögliche kollateralschäden
ohne rücksicht auf
die wirksamkeit mittlerweile hat man den
eindruck dass das ak ii früh würfelt um
danach die maßnahmen zu entscheiden
jetzt alleine daran erkennt man wie die
maßnahmen verhängen wird verhängt werden
das mittlerweile kein klares bild mehr
es ist kann zudem nicht sein dass der
gesundheitsminister mittlerweile den
panisch geführten corona diskus weiter
befeuert indem er befasste beschlüsse
und das haben wir erlebt letzte woche
nur zwei tage nach dem gipfel schon
wieder als unzureichend und weitere
massnahmen verschärfungen als notwendig
bezeichnet deswegen wurde es endlich
zeit dass auch scholz hier sein
gesundheitsminister endlich zur saison
ruft panikmache ist und bleibt kein
tragfähiges politikkonzept immer noch
wird auf die sieben tage inzidenz
geschaut stadt die auslastung der
krankenhäuser auf die wir immer wieder
auch selbst hingewiesen haben und
insbesondere der intensivstation zur
entscheidungsgrundlage zu machen dafür
müssen belastbare und aussagekräftige
zahlen auch zuverlässig erhoben werden
die krankenhaus incidents in deutschland
lag am montag bei
3,37 am sonntag hatte sie bei 3,64
gelegenheit als vergleich der bisherige
höchstwert lag um die weihnachtszeit
2020 also vor über einem jahr bei rund
15,7 5 und dies obwohl im letzten jahr
in unverantwortlicher weise tausende
intensivbetten bereits abgebaut wurden
die flächendeckende zog plus regelung
wird dramatische folgen für die bereits
stark angeschlagene gastronomie
wirtschaft haben bereits jetzt kämpft
die hälfte der betriebe ums überleben
ohne angemessene finanzielle
entschädigung wäre 2 gibt der endgültige
sargnagel auch für diese branche die
bundesregierung muss deshalb endlich und
das fordern die als fdp-fraktion eine
exit strategie für ihre
unverhältnismäßigen corona politik
vorlegen dazu gehört auch die geplante
impfpflicht umgehend und endgültig zu
stoppen die bürger die unternehmen
brauchen endlich wieder perspektiven die
perspektivlosigkeit muss beendet werden
wir brauchen planungssicherheit und auch
die fdp-fraktion rotation eigenen antrag
was zur ablehnung der korona impfpflicht
angeht einbringen das parlament noch
einmal zur allgemeinen impfpflicht auch
da bleibt unsere position die gleiche
corona impfung dienen in erster linie
dem eigenschutz die entscheidung dafür
oder dagegen muss deshalb in der
eigenverantwortung der bürger bleiben
vielen dank erstmal
der kollege gruppe hat eigentlich alles
wesentliche schon gesagt weshalb mir
jetzt die ergänzung bleibt wir sind ganz
klar der meinung darauf haben wir auch
damals hingewiesen als diese
entscheidung getroffen wurde
die impfpflicht für das gesundheitswesen
sofort aufzuheben die bundesregierung
sollte darauf drängen die impfpflicht
aufzuheben warum weil sich der
pflegenotstand dem wir ohnehin schon
seit jahren haben sich nochmal deutlich
verschlechtern wird weil viele
ungeimpfte pflegekräfte nun ihren job
kündigen müssen und dementsprechend
müssen wir darauf drängen diese
maßnahmen dahingehend zu korrigieren
dass sie verhältnismäßig sind und nicht
kontra produktiv wirken darum die
sofortige aufhebung der impfpflicht im
gesundheitswesen
fragen
neuen regeln wie jetzt hier im parlament
in kraft gesetzt werden was sagen sie
dazu und wie werden sie damit umgehen in
der parlamentarischen arbeit ja also wir
werden uns das sehr genau anschauen und
auch dagegen klagen denn sie sehen
natürlich bei denen immer neuen und
immer weitergehende beschränkungen hier
im deutschen bundestag dass das freie
mandat der abgeordneten eingeschränkt
wird und ich muss ganz klar sagen dass
auch diese maßnahmen unverhältnismäßig
sind und dementsprechend wir hier sehr
klar über die bücher gehen und auch
rechtliche schritte erwägen
ja obwohl sie die mit abstand kleinste
fraktion im deutschen bundestag ist und
gerade noch so ins parlament geschlampt
ist bei der letzten bundestagswahl für
die fraktion die linke heute besondere
aufmerksamkeit genauer gesagt die partei
und fraktionsführung der linken nämlich
hier versammelt ist und den kandidaten
der partei gerhard trabert für die
bundespräsidentenwahl vorstellen die
findet am 13 februar ja hier in berlin
statt und ich gebe ihr zweiter zur see
gehöre gerade dass sie noch nicht da
sind sich jetzt gerade erst aufstellen
also es dauert noch einen kleinen moment
am 13 februar ist die
bundespräsidentenwahl union spd fdp und
grüne haben sich ja auf die wiederwahl
des amtsinhabers
geeinigt die afg wird ende januar also
in der nächsten sitzungswoche
wahrscheinlich einen kandidaten oder
eine kandidatin benennen und die linken
die machen das jetzt der name ist
bekannt der sozialmediziner gerhard
trabert präsentation und
bundespräsidentenkandidaten
jahre zu uns gekommen sind die fraktion
hat sich vorgestellt und diskutiert war
sehr angenehm und sie haben jetzt auch
gleich die gelegenheit nachdem ihr
eingangs lebens gehört haben fragen zu
stellen mit janine wissler total
vorsitzenden bitte
ja ich freue mich sehr dass ich heute
dass wir heute gemeinsam einen so
überzeugenden und beeindruckenden
kandidaten für das amt des
bundespräsidenten vorstellen können
nämlich professor doktor gerhard trabert
der wie ich finde wie kaum jemand anders
so stark das motto verkörpert das
solidarität und teilbar ist er hat
rabatt ist allgemeinmediziner
er ist professor für sozialmedizin und
er ist bekannt als der arzt der armen
der mit seinem arzt mobil unterwegs ist
der menschen die obdachlos sind die
illegalisiert die nicht
krankenversichert sind kostenlos
behandelt der immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen hat und auch dazu publiziert
hat auf den zusammenhang von armut und
gesundheit das wer krank ist
die gefahr von armut und wer arm ist die
gefahr hat zu erkranken und gerhard
hilft menschen in deutschland er ist
aber auch international unterwegs er war
in vielen kriegs und krisengebieten
dieser welt in kurdistan in afghanistan
in syrien er war auf haiti und in
pakistan er war im mittelmeer unterwegs
bei den seenotrettern und hat menschen
vorm ertrinken gerettet und er war in
den geflüchteten lagern an den
außengrenzen der europäischen union wie
in lesbos auf in moria wo er sich
besonders engagiert hat
schwerstbehinderte menschen von dort zu
evakuieren und
deshalb finden wir dass er der richtige
kandidat ist zur richtigen zeit er
darauf hinweist auch gerade in der
korona pandemie auf die menschen die
eben nicht auf der sonnenseite der
gesellschaft stehen und wir sind sehr
froh dass der geschäftsführer
parteivorstand und der fraktionsvorstand
gestern einstimmig gerhard nominiert
haben und wir werden sehr dafür dass er
nicht nur ein angebot der linken ist
sondern dass er ein angebot ist ein
personell das angebot der genau darauf
hinweist dass die soziale ungleichheit
in diesem land so großes und ist es
natürlich auch ein schönes zeichen dass
gerd bei seiner kandidatur als
parteiloser direktkandidat für die linke
in mainz das beste ergebnis der linken
in westdeutschland mit der erststimme
geholt hat und deswegen meinen ganz
herzlichen dank dass du diese kandidatur
übernimmst und ich freue mich sehr
darauf haben wir schon johnny
hat ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt
ich finde du bist ein mensch der tat mit
ganz großem herzen und du bist einer
derjenigen menschen die man glaubt dass
es sie nicht mehr gibt ein mensch der
sich um andere kümmert selbst muss und
bescheiden und der sich darum kümmert
dass menschen ihre würde behalten können
dass menschen ihre mensch neuen
globalen auch wiedererlangen können und
all das was du leistest als das was du
mitbringen was du einen werten mit
bringst du hast uns gerade die begriffe
gleich würdigkeit und gleichwertigkeit
mit auf den weg gegeben bedeutet
natürlich vor uns in der politik auch
dass wir auch mit dir sehen welche
lücken unser gesellschaftliches system
hat dass es so viele menschen gibt die
die durch diese lücken fallen um die
sich nicht gekümmert wird die nicht vor
armut geschützt werden und auch das geht
global auch das machst du deutlich ich
kann nur noch mal sagen ich bin stolz
darauf dass du für die linke kandidiert
wir werden dafür wären das mehr als 71
stimmen in der bundesversammlung werden
vielleicht haben ja doch einen neuen
bundespräsidentin der nicht steinmeier
heißt das wäre glaube ich aus heutiger
sicht etwas
träumerei aber wir sollen ja auch alle
träumen dürfen dass die welt auch etwas
besser wird danke dir sagen
danke schön
wenn professor dr gerd rabatt sagt mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit wagen dann spricht
das uns linken aus dem herzen die
tägliche praxis unserem land die zeigt
ja dass viele menschen von der
herrschenden politik ausgegrenzt und
kaum beachtet werden es sind die ganz
armen obdachlose menschen zum beispiel
menschen die keine krankenversicherung
haben zu denen er trat mit seinem arzt
mobil unterwegs ist aber die soziale
ungleichheit die geht ja noch viel
weiter ich will nur einige beispiele wie
viele frauen verdienen zum beispiel nach
wie vor nicht das gleiche wie ihre
männlichen kollegen für die gleiche
arbeit wie viele frauen leisten
unglaubliches in der pflege bei der
kindererziehung bei der pflege von
angehörigen und landen dann trotzdem im
alter in armut
der trabert zurecht armut macht krank
und krankheit macht arm und genau
dagegen kämpft auch unsere fraktion im
bundestag wir finden dass diese themen
von der herrschenden politik zur zeit
nicht genug aufmerksamkeit bekommen und
ich möchte sagen in einer zeit in der
die spaltung der gesellschaft so tief
ist wie jetzt wo vertrauen in
herrschende politik immer mehr verloren
geht wo große teile der bevölkerung
nicht einmal mehr zur wahl gehen weil
sie die hoffnung darauf verloren haben
dass sich dadurch etwas für sie ändert
in dieser zeit ist es wichtig mit
überzeugenden mit glaubwürdigen personen
an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen um eben
deutlich zu zeigen eine andere politik
ist möglich und das versuchen wir das
möchten wir mit unserem kandidaten
besser doch der trabert
ich glaube damen und herren ich habe
eigentlich sehr wenig zu ergänzen ich
bin auch sehr froh dass du für uns
kandidiert die entscheidung nachdem die
anderen parteien sich alle auf ein
geeinigt haben und letztlich von söder
bis zu den grünen halle einen kandidaten
wollen darauf unsere entscheidung fest
dass wir eine demokratische alternative
wollen und ist ein angebot ein angebot
der diskussion insbesondere dieser zeit
die themen sind benannt wenn sie sich
die biografie von er anschauen dann ist
das nur beeindruckend da kann man nur
den hut ziehen für das was du bisher
geleistet hast und deswegen kann ich nur
sagen sind ein bisschen stolz dass du
das für uns macht und wir sind auch
stolz dass fraktion und partei da voll
dahinter steht und ich wünsche mir auch
dass es denn 71 6 werden wichtig ist
aber dass die themen in der
öffentlichkeit sind und das ist eine
demokratische alternative gibt
herzlichen dank und alles gute für die
nächsten tage
zuerst möchte ich mich einfach auch bei
der partei die linke bedanken für das
vertrauen ich bin parteilos ich bleibe
parteilos und war immer parteilos ich
war nie in einer partei aber ich war
immer politisch
es ist jetzt schon sehr viel zu meinem
engagement gesagt worden ich mache diese
versorgung wohnungsloser menschen seien
28 jahren und
es ist immer wieder gesagt worden ja
aber es ändert sich nichts
und das stimmt ich habe das gefühl dass
die soziale ungleichheit
zugenommen hat dass die
löcher in unserem sozialen netz und in
unserem gesundheitssystem immer größer
werden und die armut immer mehr zunimmt
ich habe das gefühl dass reichtum
stabilisiert wird und nicht armut
bekämpft wird und was ganz fatal ist das
zunehmende armut gegen armut ausgespielt
wird dass der deutsche obdachlose und
die aus syrien geflüchtete mann die frau
das dann gesagt wird wir haben nicht
genügend geld ressourcen um hier die
versorgung zu garantieren
und das darf nicht sein wir sind ein
reiches land wir können wir müssen mehr
soziale verantwortung übernehmen in
diesem land aber auch über die grenzen
hinweg ich war im vergangenen sommer mit
rescue chip davor mit sie bot im
mittelmeer und ich kann ihnen sagen
niemand kann durch ein bild durch einen
film ermessen was es bedeutet menschen
aus dem wasser zu ziehen kurz vor dem
ertrinken und das lässt deutschland das
liszt europa zu ich habe auch das gefühl
dass noch nie so oft die menschenrechte
von demokratien verletzt und gebrochen
wurden wie in der heutigen zeit ich war
an der grenze von bosnien herzegowina
kroatien
wo menschen in abfall häusern
abbruchhäusern leben müssen im winter
genau vor einem jahr war ich dort wo
kroatien durch push back aktion die
menschen zurückgedrängt wo sie im schnee
im wald überwintern müssen ich war auf
lesbos wo menschen unter katastrophalen
bedingungen in moria lagerleben mussten
aber ich kenne natürlich auch die
situation in deutschland und das
emotionalisiert auch das gebe ich
vollkommen zu wenn sie tagtäglich mit
der note mit der armut konfrontiert sind
wenn sie miterleben müssen wie viele
menschen nicht krankenversichert sind
und keinen zugang mehr zu unserem
versorgungssystem haben wie verlassen
sie sich vorkommen und genau das möchte
ich mit meiner kandidatur
eben in den fokus einer öffentlichen und
einer politischen debatte wieder
einbringen das thema armut hatte im
bundeswahlkampf so gut wie keine rolle
gespielt auch das thema migration
warum das sind ganz wichtige dinge das
sind ganz wichtige themen es geht um
menschen und
wenn ein bundesinnenminister sagt die
migration sei die mutter aller
politischen probleme dann ist das nicht
zu akzeptieren dass es inhaltlich falsch
und das führt meines erachtens diesen
rechtspopulismus und den rassismus gegen
dem wir uns immer wieder wehren müssen
die mutter aller politischen probleme
ist für mich die soziale ungerechtigkeit
ungleichheit
wenn sie jetzt durch die neue regierung
ja mitverfolgt haben dass der
hartz-iv-satz und drei euro erhöht wird
dann enttäuscht mich das zutiefst ich
gebe zu der mindestlohn
bürgergeld wir werden sehen was damit
wird viele andere initiativen und
projekte sind gut gehen in die richtige
richtung aber wie kann man in dieser
zeit und der korona bedingungen den
hartz-iv-satz de facto erniedrigen denn
die kaufkraft ist weniger wert durch die
inflationsrate und häufig tragisch
politiker wissen sie eigentlich was für
ein fünfjähriges kind pro tag wenn die
eltern bezieher von sozialen
transferleistungen sind für ernährung
zur verfügung steht sind noch nicht
einmal drei euro für frühstück
mittagessen und abendessen und das in so
einem reichen land
und all diese ungerechtigkeiten die
haben mich letztendlich dazu veranlasst
zu sagen ja ich mache das ich sehe das
als eine chance es geht nicht um eine
profilierung meiner person sondern es
geht um das thema armut soziale
ungleichheit das muss wieder mehr in die
politische diskussion in die öffentliche
debatte hinein kommen und da muss ich
auch was verändern und der korona zeiten
es gab eine studie von herrn tradinno im
august 2020 die eindeutig gezeigt hat
dass sozial benachteiligte menschen
bezieher von arbeitslosengeld 2 eine
höhere erkrankungsrate haben und
schwerere verläufe
das hat man nie berücksichtigt alle
wohlfahrtsverbände die nationale
armutskonferenz hat gefordert dass der
hartz-iv-satz unter corona zeiten um 100
euro pro monat erhöht werden muss dass
es nicht erfolgt durch die vorhergehende
regierung nicht und durch die jetzige
nicht
die lebensmittelpreise alles wird teurer
ffp zwei masken kostet geld da ist
überhaupt kein budget vorgesehen
selbst die grünen haben vor zwei jahren
eine expertin expertise veröffentlicht
nachdem ein hartz4 satz von ungefähr 650
euro gesellschaftliche teilhabe wieder
erlaubt
und dann gebe ich zu dann frage ich mich
warum hat das keine konsequenz warum
müssen die menschen immer weiter
ungehört am rande unserer gesellschaft
leben
ich würde susanne hat es schon gesagt in
zwei begriffe gern zum schluss noch
mitgeben wollen dass es der begriff der
gleichwertigkeit ich denke jeder mensch
ist gleich wert was geht glaube ich
manchmal etwas verloren in der
diskussion und das ist auch ein klares
statement gegen rechtspopulismus und
rassismus keinen millimeter nach rechts
und der andere begriffe ist der begriff
der gleichwertigkeit das ist ein begriff
den jesper juul an dänische
familientherapeut
eingeführt hat quasi in die deutsche
sprache es geht bei ihm um die beziehung
von eltern zu ihren kindern um eine
gelungene beziehung die von respekt und
würde geprägt ist und ich habe mir
erlaubt diesen begriff von jesper juul
zu übernehmen zu sagen das muss die
grundlage der beziehung zwischen all den
menschen aber insbesondere auch zu
die benachteiligten und ausgegrenzten
menschen seien innen mit würde und
respekt zu begegnen
und da habe ich das gefühl das ist immer
seltener der fall
und das letzte wenn man über armut redet
dann muss man auch über reichtum in
diesem reichen land reden und der korona
bedingungen sind die reichen reicher
geworden und die anbieter immer und es
hat nichts mit einer neiddiskussion in
meinen augen zu tun wenn man von einer
vermögenssteuer einer höheren
einkommensteuer auch von einer
erbschaftssteuer redet all diese
instrumente spielen jetzt auch bei der
neuen regierung keine rolle und ich
finde es ist höchste zeit hier auch eine
politik zu realisieren die soziale
gleichheit und gerechtigkeit fördert und
nicht dieses ungleichgewicht
stabilisiert dann gewinnen wir trauern
sie haben die erste frage
professor trat sie haben jetzt noch
knapp fünf wochen zeit sich in
deutschland bekannt oder bekannter zu
machen
planen sie eine art wahlkampf damit es
mehr als 71 stimmen reisen sie durch die
16 bundesländer
und haben sie pläne schloss bellevue
bleibt man bei den traum den frauen
nicht weil sie so kurz skizziert hat
hätten sie pläne schloss bellevue für
andere gesellschaftsgruppen
bevölkerungsgruppen zu öffnen als
bislang
vielen dank also gerade ihre letzte
frage bin ich schon ein paar mal gefragt
worden ja ich würde als erstes denke ich
betroffenen initiativen zum thema
wohnungslosigkeit einladen wollen und
ich bin auch immer wieder gefragt worden
aber du bist doch in der praxis so aktiv
und wenn du jetzt nur noch politisch
aktiv ist reicht dir dass ich habe stadt
vielleicht kann ja auch mal ein
bundespräsident einer also alle zwei
wochen einem arzt mobil weiter unterwegs
sein warum eigentlich nicht die nähe zu
erhalten zu menschen am rande unserer
gesellschaft warum muss da immer so eine
distanz und zu ihrer ersten frage da
werden wir gemeinsam noch überlegen wie
das sein wird unter corona bedingungen
ich meine die sozialen medien sind sind
so wichtig die öffentlichkeit sie
berichten darüber wir haben jetzt nicht
wirklich so ein wahlkampf vor aber wir
werden schon versuchen ja auch in den
ländern aktiv zu werden und was mir auch
noch mal wichtig ist ich führe keine
kandidatur gegen herrn steinmeier
sondern für von armut betroffene
menschen das ist mir auch noch mal ganz
wichtig für deutschland
wie ist da im moment die stimmungslage
in der fraktion und daran anschließend
die zweite frage sondert sich diese
stimmungslage dieses stimmungsbild
dadurch dass omikron zwar hoch infektiös
aber nicht so gefährlich also nicht so
belastend für das gesundheitssystem zu
sein scheint
also danke für diese frage wir haben uns
zum thema im pflicht vor der
weihnachtspause bereits
geäußert zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wir
haben ist die fraktionssitzung
unterbrochen auch für dieses presse
statement wir werden dieses thema in der
dann fortgesetzten fraktionssitzung
weiter besprechen gestern im vorstand
haben wir allerdings uns bereits darauf
verständigt dass wir jetzt auch was die
konkreten anträge die gruppenanträge
angeht jetzt erstmal schauen wollen was
denn da überhaupt vorgelegt wird und das
wollen wir dann bewerten sie haben es
angesprochen natürlich durch die lage
von omikron er muss man objektiv sehen
haben sich gewisse fakten lagen
verändert aber wie wir das bewährte
werden werden das werden wir der
fraktion noch besprechen
natürlich ändert sich die auch die
emotionale lage bei jedem einzelnen
durch jede neue erkenntnisse und wir
haben hier gerade jemand der professor
als präsentiert da finde ich sollte man
das was wissenschaft was andere dazu
sagen immer sehr ernst nehmen aber ich
bin vor allen dingen sehr gespannt was
denn überhaupt vorgelegt wird ich kann
mich gut erinnern der bundeskanzler
hatte gesagt zum ende des jahres wird es
anträge geben ich kenne bisher keinen
nun mag das an mir liegen aber bisher
gibt es nach meinem kenntnisstand nichts
und ich würde mir wünschen dass wirklich
etwas vorliegt wo man eine
gesundheitspolitische und rechtliche
würdigung vornehmen kann ich glaube dass
wir nahezu jeden tag neue erkenntnisse
bekommen und deswegen bin ich persönlich
dort erstmal etwas skeptisch und will
sehen was es konkret gibt jetzt höre ich
dass die union einen antrag zur
impfpflicht über 50 eventuell oder auch
eventuell nicht also ich habe beides
gelesen ich habe die schlagzeilen in
einer zeitung gelesen es gibt keinen
eigenen antrag und einer anderen zeit
und es gibt ein das finde ich schon mal
sehr beeindruckend aber mir müsste mal
einer erklären also ich habe vorhin auch
gefragt gesundheitspolitisch wieso
eigentlich 50 weißen runde zahl ist oder
weshalb also bisher finde ich wenig
überzeugen ist und ich will dass meine
das war meine ganz persönliche sicht ob
wir denn eine impfpflicht bekommen ist
der bundeskanzler angekündigt hat ich
habe da weiterhin eine gewisse skepsis
ich kenne die position weist das ist
große unterstützer einer impfpflicht
gibt allgemein in meiner partei in
meiner fraktion es gibt gegner das
empfinde ich als normal das ist nicht
zuerst eine parteipolitische frage
verzauberten auch selbst sonntag sie
haben gerade ein sehr konkretes bild
beschrieben über die zustände aus ihrer
sicht in deutschland in europa meine
frage auch wenn sie hier nicht mitglied
der linken sind aber ihre politischen
ziele
unterstützen wie erklären sie sich die
schlechte resonanz auf diese ziele warum
gibt es so wenig unterstützung bei zb
bundestagswahlen und was sagt das aus
ihrer sicht über politik in deutschland
insgesamt aus wir haben uns gerade
vorhin auch dazu unterhalten weil ich es
auch nicht so ganz nachvollziehen kann
woran das liegt also ich glaube manchmal
sind die menschen sie suchen die
stabilität in dem sie das was schon
immer in der regierung war was schon
immer
verantwortlich war für den ablauf in
unsere gesellschaft
sie versuchen sicherheit zu erlangen
indem sie das alt gewohnte wiederwählen
das ist so eine vermutung ich kann es
mir auch nicht wirklich erklären
wenn man in umfragen vor der wahl hat
man die sozialdemokratische partei als
die partei die am besten soziale
kompetenz vermittelt
ja benannt ja was was die quoten angeht
in der bevölkerung die sozialdemokratie
und die grünen haben hartz 4 geschaffen
die agenda 2010
vergisst man so schnell solche maßnahmen
die zu mehr armut geführt haben die noch
mehr das thema armut in unserer
gesellschaft forciert haben
ich habe keine erklärung ich meine da
muss vielleicht auch die linke dann
selbst dazu antworten was sie
denkt ich habe das gefühl
dass die linke schon sehr authentisch
und klar in diesem kontext sich
positioniert warum das nicht so ankommt
bei dem bürger bei der bürgerin
ich kann es mir auch nicht wirklich
erklären
aber vielleicht möchte noch jemand
was wissen
[Musik]
mit menschen die auf der straße leben
wäre denn aus ihrer sicht es ratsam für
diese menschen auch eine impfpflicht
einzuführen damit man da eben dann an
diese menschen verpflichtend war aber
überhaupt herankommt oder sagen sie das
funktioniert bei denen gerade überhaupt
nicht da kommt dann nur trotz und
widerstand und die leute verschwinden
und ducken sich ab oder verstecken sich
wie auch immer er kann ich wunderbar
darauf antworten weil das es überhaupt
kein problem bei wohnungslosen menschen
wir haben drei impfaktionen durchgeführt
ich werde von wohnungslosen menschen
häufig angesprochen doch wann können wir
geimpft werden da ist eine hohe
sensibilität eine rohe compliance sich
impfen zu lassen wir haben in drei
impfaktionen in mainz über 150 menschen
impfen können und die rate der nicht
geimpften unter den wohnungslosen ist
sehr sehr gering also da ist ein
bewusstsein da dass man in vielen
anderen bereichen der bevölkerung nicht
findet also wohnungslose menschen sind
nicht das problem
ja das wusste ich das ist ja auch klar
also ich habe keine ganz klare meinung
ich sehe es auch problematisch also
einmal ist mir immer wichtig noch einmal
zu differenzieren was impfgegner angeht
das wird mir häufig das kommt mir häufig
zu kurz ich glaube es gibt drei gruppen
eine gruppe sind menschen die in ihrem
umfeld eventuell schon mitbekommen haben
dass es zu nebenwirkungen gekommen ist
dass da irgendetwas nicht gut gelaufen
ist dann gibt es eine gruppe die sehr
stark ideologisch dogmatisch geprägt
sind wir wissen dass da die oder steiner
der antrieb europa und row
anthroposophen genau da habe ich dann
immer probleme wenn ich etwas nicht
wirklich so nachvollziehen kann die
anthroposophen das ist ja eine ganz
klare verweigerungshaltung ja da können
sie auch nicht viel machen und die
dritte gruppe sind für mich menschen die
an die demokraten sind und dieser
skepsis diesen widerstand
instrumentalisieren für ihre
rassistischen rechtspopulistischen
intentionen also es ist mir wichtig
wirklich in dieser diskussion auch
nochmal zu differenzieren und ich
wünsche mir dass man die erste gruppe
glaube ich kann man durch transparenz
durch überzeugungsarbeit noch gewinnen
die beiden anderen können sie nicht
gewinnen das glaube ich jedenfalls und
wissen sie bei einer impfpflicht also
ich bin absolut für das impfen ich bin
arzt ich bin geburtstag ich bin
befürworter aber man muss sich natürlich
auch immer damit auseinandersetzen wie
kann ich denn die impfpflicht dann
kontrollieren welche
repressionen welche bestrafung setze ich
dann ein und all das muss vorher geklärt
sein sonst sind es vielleicht menschen
die noch mehr ins abseits noch mehr
ausgegrenzt werden und das darf auch
nicht sein aber wie gesagt ich bin
selbst noch in einem reflektion und
entscheidungsprozess was die impfpflicht
angeht ich bin froh dass man jetzt
differenzierter darüber diskutiert und
nicht sagt das ist es das müssen wir
machen nein man muss sich mit den
konsequenzen auseinandersetzen
und ich glaube man hat in der
vergangenheit den fehler gemacht zu
wenig
nachvollziehbar darüber zu informieren
ja da waren immer wieder experten und
ich kenne das ja selbst
experten sprechen manchmal die sprache
die nicht unbedingt
verstanden wird und da sollte man sich
vielleicht auch noch mal gedanken machen
wie kann ich komplexe themen
nachvollziehbar vermitteln
auch wenn sie darüber gesprochen haben
ja eine frage für die fraktion nämlich
die bewertungen des gesetzentwurfes zum
heizkostenzuschuss 135 euro
einmalzahlung 175 für zwei personen
haushalt ist das das richtige mittel für
menschen die wohngeld beziehen aus ihrer
sicht wer möchte
ich gerne etwas zu danke für die für
diese frage eher selbstverständlich ist
es erstmal zu begrüßen wenn menschen die
die knapp bei kasse sind eine
unterstützung bekommen also das heißt
natürlich wenn es diejenigen die jetzt
große schwierigkeiten haben ihre
heizkosten zu bezahlen wenn sie jetzt
mit einer einmalzahlung erstmal erste
abhilfe bekommen ist das ist das ja gut
aber es löst das hauptproblem nicht denn
wir haben ja was das thema angeht
wirklich grundlegende probleme die
energiekosten steigen und steigen an und
durch einmalzahlungen werde ich diese
ist dieser problematik wirklich nicht
herr das heißt da muss man grund wegen
rangehen und was aktuell geschieht das
sagt man auch viel
klimaschutzpolitik über den verkauf über
den verbraucherpreis gemacht wird ist ja
auch ein grund für die steigende
energiekosten das halte ich schon
wirklich deutlich für falsch denn es
wird immer die menschen die jetzt schon
große schwierigkeiten haben klarzukommen
stark belasten und wir sehen gerade was
die energiekosten an geht das ja nicht
nur diejenigen die jetzt ich habe meinen
grundsicherung sind damit
schwierigkeiten haben das zu stemmen
sondern es werden immer weitere teile
der bevölkerung für die diese
energiekosten eine ernsthafte belastung
werden und das ist der falsche weg an
der stelle muss ich sagen eine steuerung
über den verbrauchspreis wird immer zu
sozialen verwerfungen führen ich halte
es für den falschen weg muss über die
preis deckel reden für verbraucher und
verbraucher nicht für die industrie
verbrauchern verbraucher und ich muss
wenn ich über so etwas rede wie soziale
bezuschussung dann aber dauerhaft und
einmalzahlungen sind da nicht der
richtige weg
so weit die vorstellung des kandidaten
der linken gerd trat für die
bundespräsidentenwahl am 13 februar die
ard will auch eine kandidatin einen
kandidaten präsentieren wahrscheinlich
in der nächsten sitzungswoche ende
januar die aufmerksamen zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern haben die führende
regierungspartei spd hier vermisst
entschuldigung fraktionssitzung erst um
17 uhr hier unter mir im plenarsaal
ein presse statement vorher von rolf
mützenich gegen 16.45 das werden wir
nach liefern so weit von der
fraktionsebene zurück ins phoenix studio
nach bonn zu bernd rasen ja danke schön
und externer kehler ja das thema
impfpflicht wird den bundestag morgen
sicherlich ausführlich beschäftigen und
das werden sie hierbei völlig
selbstverständlich mitverfolgen können
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einem
coup 19 spezial zum thema
kinderimpfungen ich hier